I've been talking today about the anti
racism protests which of course began in
the United States after the death of
George Floyd but have since spread
around the world and yesterday evening
there were some violent scenes in London
as protesters and police clashed
although it is really important to say
that the vast majority of the
demonstrations were peaceful we're now
joined by the former footballer and the
anti racism campaigner John Barnes thank
you very much for being on the program
and do you think the UK has a racism
problem like the u.s. the u.s. in terms
of black policemen killing black people
on the street as we saw with the George
Floyd the ESCO however in terms of the
disenfranchisement of the inner cities
of the black community not being given
access to healthcare social care jobs
housing it's exactly the same but of
course what we are witnessing in the US
which has outraged people is the visible
face of racism and the visible face of
racism in terms of footballers being
abused the John's florid situation and
and you know the police it's an obvious
and easy thing to be outraged about we
should be equally as outraged the fact
that our young black is an illness this
is only human education there not be
given housing and drop promotion but
possibilities so if it isn't like the US
in terms of the violence that we may see
but in terms of how impactful it is
negatively on the black community it's
exactly the same you've often spoken
about the need to speak up for what you
describe as the voiceless and to you
know really focus I guess on racism
that's experienced by underprivileged
and black communities and do you think
that there's been enough of a focus on
that when it comes to the debate on
whether the UK's racist lot there isn't
because it's about the as I said the
visible face of racism the footballers
and and the black actors and black
singers who may not got Oscars or may
not good
you know Enys and and of course from the
police perspective in terms of you know
people being stopped and being arrested
but for 90 percent more than 90 percent
of the of the black community they may
not they may not come up against that
however what they do come up against is
the fact that their children are be
given education and not be given housing
you know and access to show us all Karen
and how big the problem is so that's why
I would like the people with the
platform's my platform isn't that great
anymore I'm a footballer anymore but I
have a small platform and I will use my
platform to say how terribly
for John miles because he can't get a
job as a football manager as much as I
do know that that is an issue as well
I'll use my platform to talk about how
terrible it is for the people less
fortunate myself because until we saw
that problem out down there these racist
incidents would always happen that is
racism what we see with the George Floyd
on football managers are racist
incidents which happen and then they go
away then they happen and they go away
then they happen so until we tackle a
real problem of racism to get rid of
racism racist incidents would always
have when you're talking about the
problem of racism the constructional
inequalities on education on housing do
you think matters that there aren't any
black people around the cabinet table in
government well if you once again if you
want to see the the the visible face of
racial equality that's what you want to
call it yes we can put somebody in there
will that make anything better America
had a black president for many years is
it getting better there so yes that'll
be nice thence shown black people then
yes they are black people who can get on
but for the majority to them that will
make a difference at all
that's like saying we have a black
manager which we didn't have Paul Ince
with a black manager the Premier League
I don't know 15 years ago you know real
good it with the black manager I have
scenes change so the fact that we may
then promote black people into positions
of power doesn't change anything at all
we have to change people's perceptions
well I guess you could argue that having
black people in those positions of power
means that they understand the racism
that many underprivileged people
experience more I don't think you do
something about it yes but if you are
involved in a systemic structure of
discrimination and you become a part of
that how do you actually change that you
can't change that by yourself
Obama can change it by himself the black
football manager who won the Champions
League being a successful black manager
he couldn't change that because it is
systemic so it's okay saying that yes
they kept going down and change think is
very difficult to change things from
within
um this week Lee Francis said he was
deeply sorry for his portrayal of black
people and based electro and you said
that actually you'd quite like him to
keep doing his impersonations of Craig
David and Michael Jackson because you
enjoy them and do you understand why
people were offended by them I could
understand why people were offended by
them in terms if they felt that there
were a negative representation of black
people but they weren't there are
negative represent
of Craig David and of is it a negative
representation of Michael Jackson to
dance and sing and do what he did and as
much as Craig David may have suffered
that is an individual thing that that is
not a negative representation of black
people he was being particular about
those particular people he did Elton
John are gay people gonna be upset
because he did a gay man if he did a
generic black man like what blackface is
the black and white minstrels and just
saying here is a black man talking
rubbish then I could understand that but
you're doing a specific person because
as I mentioned the gay community should
be in arms up in arms because he also
the negative representations or making
fun of Elton John do you feel it's like
s fees into argument that sometimes
we're looking too much at the symbols
rather than the the racism that's
experienced by and so many millions of
black people in inner cities and
elsewhere
well first of all we have to analyze
what we consider to be races are not and
there's lhasa
that is racist and there's some that
isn't but unfortunately you have two
sides of that it's not a binary
situation you've got two sides of the
argument where right people say
everything is racist and some people say
nothing Tracy and I'm having a big
problem and lots of criticism because
I've been criticized by so many white
people are saying I'm saying everything
is racist and then I'm criticized by a
lot of black people are you who are
saying to me you're saying nothing's
racist that's why you have to take each
and every argument discussion debate on
its own merits
it does feel like it in a minute there's
some kind of soul searching going on
among all people I guess in a new
country but white people like myself as
well on you know how we could all time
work together to make things better what
would your advice be on those steps that
we can take to try and make society less
racist don't just look at the visible
signs of racism like the Georg Freud and
the and the very short man and Amy
Cooper and when you actually see it to
be outraged then be offended and really
say we're gonna do something about it
because that happens intermittently what
continues throughout every single day
and black people's lives in inner cities
is the systemic racism that affects
their our daily lives every day and
that's that's more important for us to
challenge that than these incidents
because until we challenge that to break
that down deconstruct what we have
wrongly learned about each other
I say racism is understandable because
what we have been wrong what we have
wrongly been told about different roots
of people be they black people be they
women do they gays we have been wrongly
told for hundreds of years
negative subliminal
about those people so therefore it is in
so many of us but we don't admit it we
don't only to don't acknowledge it but
we wait to see the visible face of
either homophobia or sexism like Harvey
Weinstein or or what happens with Jorge
Freud and then we're outraged and then
when you don't see it we don't think
about it with this is a continual effort
to this become shot racism not deep not
to stop individual racist incidents
you're right that it's something that we
should always think about all the time
clearly and now you have experienced
racism in your career yourself there's
that kind of iconic picture I guess if
you back healing away a banana at the
Merseyside derby in 1988 do you ever get
young black players asking you for
advice today that's always hard for me
to give people advice because they're
all individuals and when people say this
is how black people should think this is
what we should do I can't advise a black
player he has to do what's right for him
the way I reacted maybe the different
way here Ian right in European right yes
however I will say this I didn't
experience racism I experienced lots of
racist incidents because that races
incident that I went through when a
banana came on the field on the Saturday
on the Sunday Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday John Brown's a
footballer famous lived in a nice house
drives a nice car
people are living into restaurants into
bars into shops didn't experience racism
whatsoever then on a Saturday a banana
came on the field
black people every single day Indiana
cities experience racism every single
day and that's what we have to that's
what we have to dismantle yes we have to
stop the racist internet so John's Freud
the bananas coming on but until we do
look at it the other way and say let us
get rid of racism in society they will
always have races internets and I
understood that so when I was being
racially abused I listened to the stand
that I saw black for both hands and who
know I'm speaking for them the whole
problem was John bass he's being
racially abused what about black
football fans who have to get to the
game five minutes after the game started
and leave five minutes before and when
they're walking down the street but no
one speaks for them we always speak for
the the John bounces of this world under
and the black elite if you like and
that's why I think as a so-called
celebrity a lead person leader of the
black community we should be speaking
for them and that's that's what I do so
I know we need to get more back managers
and black actors getting Oscars and
stuff like that but I will always speak
for the community first thank you very
fascinating to talk and and to talk
about how you want to use your platform
to try and you change these perceptions
and just what we've got you have to ask
and do you think it's right that the
Premier League's returning the Premier
League is returning and in the way
that's returning in terms of it being as
safe as as is possible in terms of the
the structure that's put in place to try
and obviously stop people getting
coronavirus and the fact that it's going
to be behind closed doors so I think
they can control you can manage that
situation um so yeah I think it's
returning but I was listening to the
gentlemen before talking about when
should it return should it be on the
17th should it be later some people have
an opinion that it should be later some
people say it should be earlier we
really don't know it's a testing time
but I think you know they will be able
to manage that situation so I'm looking
forward to thank you so much for coming
the program this morning much
appreciated our John bonza